it was an obvious Target strategic and
symbolic connecting the Russian Mainland
with illegally annexed Crimea and not
quite as secure as Russia must have
hoped
a massive explosion tearing one section
of the bridge apart early Saturday
morning one day after Vladimir Putin's
70th birthday
Russia's investigative committee says
the blast was caused by a truck bomb and
has identified the truck's owner as a
resident of the city of krasnada
according to preliminary data this
morning a truck exploded on the road
section of the Crimea Bridge from the
side of the Taman Peninsula this set
seven fuel tanks of a train traveling in
the direction of Crimea on fire as a
result two Road sections have partially
collapsed
Chief advisor to Ukraine's president
tweeted straight after the blast Crimea
the bridge the beginning everything
illegal must be destroyed everything's
stolen returned to Ukraine everything
occupied by Russia must be expelled
hours later another tweet pointing to
the failure of Russia's security service
to stop the blast defense Ministry can
now blame FSB for the future South loss
he writes isn't it obvious who made an
explosion truck arrived from Russian
Federation
blaming terrorism gives Russia's
president a possible way out rather than
escalating against Ukraine he has yet to
make any kind of Declaration Beyond
calling for full criminal investigations
but this bridge was dear to him a symbol
of the reclaiming of Crimea eight years
ago built by one of his old Pals arcadi
Rottenberg at huge expense a key piece
of infrastructure waiting to be hit
and these astonishing images will
reverberate across Russia a sign if ever
there was one that his special military
operation is having unintended
consequences even as the clamorer voices
calling for a tougher military response
to Russia's losses on the battlefield
further adds to the pressure on Vladimir
Putin Diana McNeese Sky News Moscow